this capsule we will define more
formally what are the problems
of satisfaction of constraints so a
point of satisfaction constraints are going
be defined by firstly a
set of variables the whole ends
so as a set of variables life
which will contain the variable they have
extract one up to x men where n is going to be the
number of variables in our problems
and to each variable etc if we go
associate a domain and value xi
possible that can take the variable
then it has more than the other set of
variables and domains for each
variables we will roll together
constraints we're here it's a
up to cm
so m will match the number of
constraints and each of the constraints in
actually restore the values ​​that can
take a subset of variables
have examples sometimes for
illustrates a little more concretely what
that we mean by a constraint
then we note that in a problem we
go in a satisfaction bonus
constraint one make me more explicit
structure in variable to structure
in variable assigned to values ​​of
our problem so a problem state
which will correspond to one hour in
our research group are going
correspond to a value assignment
from certain variables to certain
values
so we will note that as a whole where
for example the variable etc what will be
signed a given value will live there
I will be signed a value of the gis
institute is so we will also say
that an assignment that steals that violates
none of the constraints are going to be
competitive or legal it's the
definition of equal compatible this is a
association that violates any of the
constraints also of that we will define
as a complete assignment a
assignment which involves all
variables so that would be a subpoena
who would give who has thing he is a
value to all of all
variables of our problem is so a
solution a satisfaction problem
against a calf correspond to a
assignment which is complete so who
assigns a value to all
variables and which in addition is compatible
or legal so that respects all
constraints
a first example on the example jouels
for well good simple port and of
to concretize a little all the concerts
let's imagine we are a set of barry
had that would correspond to three
variables that we note x1 x2 and x3 next
suppose that for simplicity we have that
the domain the first variable the
second variable and the third
variable be exactly the same at
know all of the Caribbean 1 2 and 3
and suppose we have one
constraint that would correspond to
constraints that x do more x must be
equal to aix 3 then for this problem of
satisfaction against 1
we will have three solutions
possible be we assign x 1 to 1 x 2 to
1 then x 3 to 1
actually we only have one plus one more
a babies equal to 2 where we could
assign x 1 x 2 2 x 3 to 3 we would not see
although 1 + 2 equals three and one
could be changed the assignment
dexter and ii x2 which would make that dre x
hours that would be equal to two experts
who feast on 1
and that's really the situation of
extras required and 363 these are three
assignment that are complete and
competitive
another example would be the riddle
next so let's imagine we give you
a map of australia and we will
request with only three colors of
color the map so that two
border states does not wear the same
color is not identified at the same
color
so in that if we have the states of
australia
we have one two three four four five sets
some share borders so
for example registers to share a
border with western australia and the
what we are asking is that the fathers of the
rates that share a border is
not the same color and that we succeed in
color all the red evening states
in green or blue so a way of
represent this problem there in the frame
a fan of constraint satisfaction
it would be to identify as variable
all the states of australia whose
notes with acronyms w at
western australia and poor for an order
territory and so on
this is the domain of each variable that
would be the three possible colors to
hergé and b or
green or blue and we administer to
also in fact we will use in the
next classes capture for
illustrate the set of variables d
state and possible values ​​of
each of the variables was not understood
this part is correct in a
next capsule we will see how
we can use this visualization
the water just to illustrate the
problem is well understood and finally
the constraints it's worth such that all
border state pairs must
have different colors so the
variable w at the hotel different sa
other value different from the value
mt actively western australia must
have a different color than northern
territory because these are states
who share a border
we would also have that mt should be
different from ass so no of a
territory must have a color
different from queensland is instituted and
for this problem there we do we see a
solution here where w register or junta is
strict
q will be red nsw very green vis à vis
will also be his reds is to this dream
blue and des would be vain so we see
visually that indeed no
pair of state territory sharing
a border have the handrail
there is an illustration a way of
draw or illustrate the constraints
of a problem that will sometimes be
practice if we have problems that have
pinaire constraints so against
in binary we will say constraints
which involves only two variables
finally we can visualize all
constraints using a graph two
against one and in this case this tale this
what we would do is we would decide
graph where each would correspond to a
variable ok so double life to recent
are our interests are naked and we
would draw an arc between the variables that
share one against a gift that are
in the same country for example w run
constraint with mtw one must not be
equal amt and institutes so that's it
what we are going to call is what we are going
call a constraint graph
associated or even
satisfactions coloring constraints
graffiti for the map of Australia
a third problem that could be
solved using an algorithm of
satisfaction against is the one d and rain
we have an example here with 8 reindeer
it's a problem we've seen in
capsules the previous
so I would not describe it again
what I want illustrated by cons is
the number of possible configurations of
our graph so forgiveness of in our
search space a number of
reindeer grid configurations
possible depending on the number of reindeer
and therefore the size of the grid and is
what we notice is that this figure
increases very quickly point that for
an equal 16 we have a number really very
high which would make it impossible
in fact
list all the grids with
positions brent up to find one that
satisfies the constraints and faces two
manners
cass of where really so that's a
example of problems Wales 16 or
a satisfaction bonus constraint is
particularly useful and necessary
to solve solve a problem so
to model this problem the dm reindeers
in the form of breads of satisfaction
of constraints
we could have as variable the
different columns one up n the
domains of each of the variables it's
do an entire two hours until end
who did what a clue to tidy up
cultural indicates ronan she
ranged one would place the queen in
this column and so the column i / o the
value as if the queen for the column
is there in the row what so
and finally for what it is
constraint one would have the whole one is
a constraint by row and by
diagonal possible the constraint this
would there be only who have
no reindeer on the same rage and so
that would mean that would imply as
we want it in the bonus d is true
that there are no reindeer that attack
directly or indirectly and noticed
that we might have expected and what
which is also constraints on
the columns but actually because of
our definition of the problem to know
we have one variable per column and
we can take as values
only at risk and so
implicitly that means we can
place a single queen only by
column and so we do not need to
constraint finally to make sure that
there are not two reigns on each column and
here we have a solution to the problem of
showcases and you notice that
actually if we look at each of
rows and each of the diagonals
liautaud days only a queen at
plus a queen on each row
August to canal